violet davis will play you in first
ladies what do you think of that casting
viola davis is the greatest you said it
i mean
you know i i feel that i'm not worthy
okay
it's exciting and anything viola does
she does it with
passion and and vigor and i know she
will do uh
no less for this role
if you want to be great chefs you have
to learn about all kinds of different
foods
hi i'm waffles and this is mochi hello
waffles and mochi are you ready for an
amazing adventure
how are you dealing with the pandemic
how's it feel you know we're
we we have our health and we are
together as a family
and we are not getting on each other's
nerves so we count our
blessings that's a good ques waffles and
mochi what have you guys
been doing during the pandemic i mean
we've been at the supermarket with you
every day all the time
they are essential workers we are
certainly essential
right i know busy says that we're not
but we are yeah
busy only thinks he's essential no it's
true
yeah we've been you know we've been
hanging in there we've been uh watching
a lot of netflix
miss obama i wanted to ask you why did
you want to make waffles in mochi
you know i remember when my kids were
little
and there wasn't a lot of tv
that i wanted to watch with them there
was a lot of great kids tv
but to have a show that i thought was
funny
and that was entertaining for them that
was exciting that took you around the
world
that uh you know that that would teach
them
about experiencing different kind of
foods this is exactly the kind of show
i would have wanted and right now re
let me tell you i would watch this show
even without my kids
because it is hilarious wait wait wait
you keep saying tv
show i thought those were our home
videos it's true it's true but some
people
see us on tv waffles so i know
it's a shock yeah yeah
what is a what is an average meal like
sitting at the obama household
and especially when you have waffles and
mochi there
well you know we we try to eat dinner
together as a family every night that's
a
pretty important ritual
you know so we usually have dinner at
about 6 30
and that's pretty regularly and
we have different kinds of foods
that's my favorite pizza is on the list
it's one of the favorites but
it's pretty balanced we usually try to
have a delicious protein
and a vegetable and depending upon what
i'm trying to accomplish
for me personally i may not have a car
but they're
my husband who needs lots of food eats
tons of carbs so we try to make sure
it's balanced but the most important
thing about dinners at our house is that
we eat together
and that's an important time for us to
catch up and
to just even in quarantine when we would
be apart all day
in separate rooms it was just a good way
to check in to see each other to ask how
our days were going even though nothing
was going on
um and we we had that we've had that
ritual for our entire lives
um even in the white house uh i read
about how the president no matter how
busy he was he would stop his day
and make sure we could have dinner
together as a family and hopefully
this show will encourage families to do
just that to take
meal times together you know to just set
aside that time
to be together i have to say all of your
meals make my waffle tummy feel so good
[Laughter]
oh what do your daughters think of
waffles and mochi and are they falling
dreams like waffles yeah they
love waffles and mochi they were the
the first ones i showed some of our
adventures to
and they la that's when i knew that this
was a special
partnership that we had here because
they're not kids anymore
they're 22 and 19.
and they were mesmerized they teared up
in episodes the lessons that they
learned
even the fun facts i mean knowing
whether tomato is a vegetable or a fruit
when we
that that caused us a little pause you
know
so even they learned something new
uh what was it what was it like because
you went to so many different places and
you had
you had so many guests and who are some
of your favorite guests from this first
season
because i'm sure there'll be a second
well waffles and mochi you guys took the
adventures i was stuck
at the grocery store yeah we just took
the magikarp all over the world
and we learned all about so many
ingredients
we met chef masamo batura remember that
in italy
who's your favorite chef uh all of them
that's right they're all pretty great
yep
you know i love all the episodes i mean
kevin it's hard for me to pick a
favorite or
favorite guest it's like asking me to
decide which child i love best
they're all great um but the first
episode which sets the tone it's
the tomato episode you know i i just
love the scene
uh where waffles and mochi are cooking
with
jose andreas and they're making gazpacho
and just the the beauty and the message
that he delivered that we're you know we
come from
like the tomato we come from everywhere
we look like all kinds of things and
when we work together and we blend
harmoniously
you get something delicious and
something special
and i like that the shows not only
do something fun and take families
around the world but there's always a
message at the end
there's always a lesson that waffles and
mochi bring back
to me uh from their adventures and
hopefully that
you know that helps to spark some
conversation at homes around the world
ooh mrs zoe and badges do you remember
that oh yes
can't forget the badges oh yeah well and
we've got this really great
website waffles and mochi.org where you
can um
families can get on and they can
interact with the show
and kids can earn their own badges so we
really want this to be
an interactive kind of show not just
while you're watching it but
people can join in on some of the fun
and go to the website
by the way is this an extension kind of
of your garden at the white house that
you had because you know we had a chance
to spend some time there
yeah this is the perfect extension the
next step it
absolutely is i mean that's one of the
reasons why the pitch for this show just
resonated with me personally
because i knew i wanted to find a way to
continue the conversation
about healthy eating and movement and
waffles and mochi does it in a
fun and creative way we're still working
with the partnership for a healthier
america
not just to talk about eating eating
well and trying new things
but we're working to raise money uh to
feed
one million families that are going
hungry right here
in the united states and so
waffles and mochi isn't just about fun
and learning it's about
doing something good in the world so
folks can go to wafflezamochie.org and
learn more about
the pass the love campaign it's been
hard to stay at home
and not go to school is there a message
you have
for kids who miss their friends
yeah i mean i you know i i know
it's tough out there on a lot of kids um
because no one expected this to happen
and
you know the the tough thing about going
through hard times like this
is one of the things that gets you
through is having perspective
but when you're young you don't have
anything to draw from
and it feels like this is an eternity
but i want kids to know that this
too shall pass and pretty soon once
everybody gets vaccinated and we know
that
everyone can be safe again schools will
open up
life will begin and you're gonna have a
lifetime to spend with your friends so i
don't want kids to get too
down uh during this period um and
hopefully
they can tune into waffles and mochi and
you guys can help cheer some kids up
right
i mean give us a couple seconds and
we'll be dancing
i want to ask you real quick before we
go violent davis will play you
in first ladies what do you think of
that casting and
i mean i mean what is the greatest viola
davis
is the greatest you said it i mean you
know i i feel that i'm not worthy
okay i wish i could be better
to live up to the character that biola
has to play
um but it is you know it's it's exciting
and anything viola does she does it with
passion and and vigor and i know she
will do
no less for this role
[Music]